today
is the last day of stoic week 2014
seven days where we devote ourselves to
thinking about stoic philosophy both in
its classical forms and it's
neostoic which actually includes
everything from medieval philosophy
up to the present forms and
this year i actually got involved in it
i'd like to talk a little bit about
some of the interesting developments
from that but i have to give
from the very beginning kind of a shout
out or kudos to the university of exeter
people who put together stoic week and
publicized it
and have been doing so for the last
several years they've developed a lot of
really great resources for people who
want to
apply themselves to to learning about
this this ancient philosophical school
and they've developed a lot of practical
resources for how to incorporate it into
your daily life which is perfectly
aligned with what stoicism was about
because it is a very practically
oriented
philosophy so what i'm going to talk
about
in in this video is the course that
i was enrolled in over the last week
um this modern stoicism course
i'll mention the the videos as the
seventh of
of the videos that i have produced for
stoic week part of my own
contribution in my channel
um talk a little bit about some other
things that i was involved with
punk rock philosopher show my you know
reblogging stuff
and then i'm going to give my my
reflections as
a philosophy professor somebody who does
philosophy in a public way
about what stoic week has has meant for
me
because it's actually been quite quite a
useful you might say
reminder and retreat on my part
so i'll talk about the course in a
minute i do want to mention
if you're interested i've shot seven
videos including this one
the first one is is really about
stoicism week and about the movement of
stoicism it's kind of a general overview
the middle five are all on particular
stoic thinkers
and stoic texts so cicero's stoic
paradoxes senecas on anger
epictetus and coridian caribbean
epictetus discourses passages on anger
and then finally marcus aurelius's
meditations passages on anger why anger
because that's an area in which i do a
lot of research and the stoics as it
turns out
have an awful lot to tell us that's
that's quite useful about that
i mentioned the punk rock philosopher
that's a friend and colleague of mine
who has a radio show in which he mixes
together
music and discussions about philosophy
he's available on spreaker usually
airs about once a week and this week
during stoicism week he did a special
show
precisely about stoicism it's usually a
bit of fusion he's doing some
comparative discussion of east
meets west kind of stuff so i'll put a
link to that
uh if you if you you know want to check
it out in the video description
i reposted some blog material in my
you know my social media stuff because
i've written about stoicism
in the past and i've been thinking a lot
about stoicism and anger
for several years so i reposted that
i'll probably also if i get around to it
today
write a blog post in my main blog rex's
dino etiquette about stoicism week and
about why i think it's a great idea
for people to participate in so let's
talk
first about the actual course
as somebody who teaches online courses
and workshops i'd like to say that this
is a very well put together course
the instructors had a lot of great
materials developed
in a wide range of formats
and it was well thought out how the the
participant should sequence through it's
tough to do stuff like this in seven
days
in a way it's less like a course and
more like an extended workshop
so i think they did a great job in
putting it together they provided it
free of charge to anybody who wanted to
enroll in it
they'll be doing that again i'm sure
next year so if you missed it this year
enroll next year and i'm sure they'll
have even more stuff available
um what did they have so they they
developed a
like a textbook they called it a
handbook and they were modeling that of
course after epictetus handbook
and what the handbook does is introduces
you not just to the nuts and bolts of
the the course structure
but to keys stoic passages
key stoic thinkers stoic texts and tries
to bring it together
in a integrated whole by the end of the
course
so in the handbook they they have you
know how the week is supposed to go
the kind of things that you're supposed
to be thinking about and it's tied in
with
uh morning and evening meditations you
can call them or or
contemplative practices and they produce
some
mp3s again those are those are available
um i think more or less publicly
you can download them they're great to
to use
to try to think about these stoic
concepts and how you would put them
to work in your own life if you've done
any you know mindfulness
meditation stuff you'll recognize some
of the uh
themes to that but the stoics did that
way better than the contemporary
mindfulness people in my
view so these are quite useful
they also created a forum uh in which
there were topics for
each day and during the the midday
reading there's a you know about a
one-page
passage that you would read from one of
the classic texts and it tied in with
the morning
and evening discussions you would you
would post and you would look at what
other people posted
and maybe chime in yourself about you
know
responses to what they're they're saying
or if people had questions
um i thought it was pretty pretty good
discussions
that went on there and i learned a lot
myself in seeing what other people were
making of it
that's really the purpose of a
discussion forum in a class anyway
you learn in part not only by you know
thinking yourself and writing something
down
on your own part but by seeing what the
other people have put
so it was a great course i i really
enjoyed it
there wasn't as much participation or
interaction as there
could be i suppose but that's something
that happens quite
often in online courses especially when
you have a wide range of people
who are involved and especially when
you're doing it worldwide
so that you know some people are posting
at one point in the day and other people
are posting at another point
other people at other points so that's
that's really to be expected
the the discussion that was there there
were a few threads that were you know
quite extended and i thought those were
quite good
a lot of insight going on there i should
point out too that i didn't participate
in any of the
worldwide events because none of them
are are near here
or near enough somewhere in new york
city but i don't get down to the city
very often
but some of these people who are
participating it were
able to go to the main events in in
britain or went to some of the other
events worldwide
and so there's some discussion about
that in the forums as well which is you
know pretty cool it's tied in with
with something big that's that's
happening so
that's really all i need to say about
the course other than if you if you
missed it this year
i'm sure it'll be available next year
it'll probably have even more features
by that time i know i'm gonna sign up
for it again next year
um i there were a few people in it who
had been in it the year before
and uh there's there's always gonna be
some some new material to it so i think
it's really worthwhile to do
my own reflections um
this is almost it turned into a bit of a
retreat for me
and that was a really good thing
in a lot of respects i i'm somebody who
always has a lot of irons
in the fire a lot of projects that are
lined up
and and i'm sometimes a bit overwhelmed
by just how much i'm trying to get done
and this was adding something a pretty
heavy commitment to it you know
doing the readings carrying out the
meditations
shooting these these videos uh on my own
part participating in the forum
discussions
and you know thinking about about
stoicism in a very dedicated way for for
seven days
um so for me it was great to go back
over some of the materials that i hadn't
looked at
for you know about a year or so
particularly the aurelius's meditations
i'm reading epictetus you know
pretty much monthly because there's
something in there
sooner or later that i'm going to teach
or i'm going to write about
seneca a little bit less often although
the discussion on anger is something
that i've been looking at quite a bit
cicero i'm probably reading about as
often as i'm reading epictetus but i
also
tend to read cicero just for fun which
is you know
kind of strange taste but there's really
a lot of great great stuff there in him
so it was good to go back over these
materials
as as an instructor as a researcher
because
you always find new things in them these
are these are inexhaustible that's why
they're classics
same thing you can say about plato
aristotle
augustine you know all the way down to
people like you know
dostoyevsky or orilka or or heidegger
you're always going to find new stuff in
them
so it's always worthwhile to have
somebody kind of steer you back to
paying close attention to them
um for me
i i actually did get some some good
work done on some of the projects that
i've got going on
with respect to uh thinking about anger
stoicism has a lot to say about it's
it's at it's it's at one
strong extreme which is that anger is
almost always a bad thing
uh and you know we should try to root it
out
i'm more aristotelian when it comes to
anger myself
um but you know that's that's
neither here nor there it's always great
to to delve into
some really you know substantive
discussions about that
and so i got some good some good notes
taken some good insights about
just what i'm going to write about when
it comes to some of the writing projects
that i've got
going on right now about anger and uh
the uh the monthly talk series that i'll
be doing over
2015 at the kingston library which is
actually about
anger this this year so the stoics will
figure into that
um you know it really drove home to me
as i'm re-reading this material that the
stoics are
uh in a lot of senses of this term a
great school of philosophy
they they really matter to the history
of philosophy
and there's good reasons why stoicism
keeps popping up when you think that
it's
it's sort of become old hat and nobody's
really interested in it
go another 100 years and then there's a
revival of stoicism
why because it responds to some
perennial needs that we have
that we we can't get away from some
things about the human condition
and some some approaches some insights
some some practices
that are really useful with with it so
um i think it you know that that was
something that was driven home to me
another thing that that's very clear to
me is
i ought to spend a lot more time doing
practical
or contemplative exercises when it comes
to these uh
these philosophies not necessarily just
stoicism
i'm also quite attracted to neoplatonism
to aristotle and to various christian
authors
and i i ought to make more time
during the day to do some of these
contemplative
exercises because they really bear a lot
of fruit
um i i think i've been sort of
not cutting corners so much as as
just not finding the time for doing that
you know there's 24 hours in the day and
you devote this much to videos and this
much to
reading and this much to writing and
this much to cooking things or
or you know housework or whatever it is
that you're doing
and then you you know you putter around
for this amount here
you know add in as many other things as
you can and sooner or later that 24
hours gets pretty filled up
and it's very easy to say i don't have
time to do
this kind of practice i don't have time
to you know set you know
15 minutes aside to do a a contemplation
at the beginning of the day but you know
the question isn't how much time you've
got it's it's the quality of the time
and if that's actually going to affect
the quality
of the time that you've got because it's
helping to change your mindset on things
that's really valuable this is one of
those sort of things that
you know i talk about and don't often
practice
uh as much as i as much as i could or
or should so stoicism week has been good
for driving that home to me as well
it also helped me rethink some some
priorities
and commitments on my own part in part
because
the you know the exercises that got you
know the prompts that we were supposed
to engage in
got me thinking about how how many
things i
i take on and try to get done
you know some viewers respond to my
videos by saying i don't know
you know how how he has the energy to do
this and i i don't either
i've been um sort of running on reserves
for
for quite a long time and maybe it's
time to start pairing back
some of the uh the levels of commitment
so i'm just doing
two or three people's jobs instead of
five uh
and my wife can actually relate to that
we're one of those kind of couples where
we're always doing a million different
things because we're trying to get a lot
of
what we view as as important and
valuable work done but
maybe it's time to you know pull back a
bit
and not have so many deadlines and not
have so many
you know plans and projections that's
something that's coming out of stoic
week for me as well
i mentioned my my wife and she also
participated
in in stoic week that was something i
was really happy about
so we were able to do at least some of
the exercises it had to do
you know early on it had to do with job
stuff but
we had because of the thanksgiving uh
break
we were able to do a lot of the
exercises together
and talk about them and think about
stoicism
together i'm reminded actually of the
example
of a famous couple from antiquity who
are not stoics but precede the stoics
the the guy
actually was the teacher of xeno who
became you know the founder of stoicism
croatase
and hipparchia two cynics two cynic
philosophers
who who were married and you know
it was really nice to be able to to do
to have the time set aside like i said
it was almost like a little bit of a
retreat
to focus just on on this
philosophical school on these thinkers
on these texts to talk about it a bit
um to cut out that that um
or fit in that
part of the day here and there in a
regular way
and that's something i think we're going
to continue on doing in part using these
stoic weak
exercises some of the these guided
meditations that they have
because some of them are very useful
and also you know looking at some some
other texts and other practices
so that's what stoic week um did for me
um i guess you know if i had to pick
just one word to describe it i would say
it was like going on
on retreat the last thing i want to talk
about
the year ahead what's you know what's
coming next well
the university of exeter people
are doing some interesting uh
compilation of survey data to see
whether
this stoic week made a difference in
people's
um in their lives how they view life how
they view happiness
their their emotional comportments their
levels of satisfaction
and that's that's very interesting stuff
i'm not so big on empirical research
because i see a lot of you know
um holes in in how these things are
designed and interpreted but hey other
people want to do that sort of stuff
that's great and if we can come up with
empirical
data that seems to support the idea that
studying philosophy is good for you
i can get behind that um whatever the
the university of exeter
the the you know the stoicism the modern
stoicism people
uh keep on doing i think i want to
follow along with that
and uh if if there's any possibilities
for partnership or collaboration in the
future i think i'm gonna
gonna actively pursue that they were
nice enough to
uh tweet about my videos when i when i
did them so that's really cool
i have to say thank you for that um
what am i gonna do here for for the next
year
well i'm gonna shoot some i was gonna i
thought about shooting stoicism videos
having to do with the history of
stoicism for stoicism week
and then i realized nah you know in the
spring i'm planning on bringing out a
history of philosophy channel and i'd be
better off to put that stuff in there
so you know this spring or perhaps this
summer depending on how the production
schedule goes
you can look for some videos talking
about
the stoic school and its development you
know the early stowa middle still
late stoa neo stoicism in
in the christian era
and then in the renaissance and then in
early modernity
and all the way down to the present i'll
do a series on those and i'll do series
on other
um schools of philosophy as well but
i've got some wind in my sails for doing
the stoicism stuff
i'm also i've also decided i'm going to
develop i'm doing a lot of online
teaching
not just for marist college but also for
a plano
and for some other
organizations and platforms as well but
i think i'm going to in the next year
develop a 12-week online class
in stoicism a really serious
study of this bearing credit college
credit
and um yeah i'll i'll produce that it'll
be for
for a plano um if there's other
platforms that are interested maybe i'll
see about
about doing it for them as well because
i think there's enough
interest out there on the part of the
the public
to have a college class on this so i'll
be doing that
um i'm going to do some online shorter
courses
in some of the other platforms that i
work with
i can put links to that or you can find
those by looking me up on my
you know various online presences and
then
i want to start thinking about what to
do
next year we were a full year out now
next november
it would be really cool i think to have
stoicism week events
not only down in the city in new york
but up here in the hudson valley
so everywhere from like you know
westchester up to to albany
i didn't see anything going on this time
it may be
up to us at reason io to organize these
events
to find partners but now we've got a
whole year to do that
and i think there's enough people in
this area that are interested in ideas
interested in philosophy interested in
history interested in the humanities
that there should be some organizations
and some audiences receptive to
to doing something the only snag and i
do have to point this out
is that the way that these these british
people
set up the event it's always going to
happen during the week that includes
thanksgiving
so it's a little bit of a tough sell i
think for some places
to do that but you know we're going to
start putting our thinking caps on and
brainstorming about that
and hopefully by the beginning of the
year we're going to start sending out
some some
feelers or inquiries to local
organizations
and other you know
other institutions about stoicism
stoicism week 2015.
so there you go this is the last video
it's not a very academic video it's more
of a wrap up and reflections
stoicism week 2014 has been a great
experience for me
as somebody who has read and thought
and talked and and taught about this
stuff for years i really got a lot out
of it
i think some of the other professors who
were involved got a lot out of it
i think that the the other people who
are
students lifelong learners professionals
just people interested in this sort of
stuff probably got a lot out of it as
well
so i highly recommend getting involved
with stoicism week next time that it
rolls around
next november